c'est le grand départ vers le début sans
aucun doute d'une longue saga judiciaire
entourée d'une quinzaine d'associés dans
son fils Eric Trump dans notre chambre
quitte Mara Lago vers midi
sur la route quelque partisans il
rentrera rapidement dans les défis où il
passera à la nuit notre chambre la
presse du monde entier et là pour ce
moment sans précédent un président
américain mis en accusation au pénale
pour la première fois dans l'histoire du
pays c'est historique mais comme le
personnage
en plus d'un énorme dispositif de
sécurité 35000 policiers sont en état
d'alerte les services secrets qui
escortent tout présidant seront appuyés
par la police de New York et la police
de l'État de New York qui doivent aussi
assurer la sécurité de Donald Trump
dit le maire de New York mais des gens
comme mold Reeder green qui propage un
discours haineux devront bien se tenir
les lieux républicaines appelé les
partisans de Donald Trump a manifesté
mardi matin près du palais de justice
contre ce qu'elle appelle une chasse aux
sorcières contre l'ancien président
mais ces partisans étaient peu nombreux
devant l'édifice Chantal
président demeurent minoritaires drapés
de fodola Marnie alassa affirme qu'il
est temps que dans notre chambre soit
face à la justice qui vous foyer
ses avocats évaluent maintenant leurs
options
policière un trajet qui risque de durer
au moins une demi-heure il comparaîtra à
14h15 devant le juge ses avocats
affirment qu'il va plaider non coupable
et c'est en soirée que l'ancien
président va livrer un discours Amara
Lago en Floride